من العاملات في الخطوط الأمامية إلى القيادة
من المقدمة ، لعبت النساء دورًا رئيسيًا
في هزيمة الوباء العالمي
ولكن في أجزاء كثيرة من العالم ، تم التراجع عن الكثير
من التقدم المحرز في مجال المساواة بين الجنسين
من سلامة المرأة إلى التعليم إلى
فرص العمل
في مكان العمل
في العام الماضي وحده ، خسرت النساء 800 مليار
دولار سنويًا من
الدخل وفقًا لمنظمة أوكسفام
الدولية وهذا أكثر من إجمالي
الناتج المحلي المشترك لـ 98 دولة
، وحل المشكلة ليس فقط
للحكومات ، حيث قال وكيل الأمين العام للأمم المتحدة
إن اقتباس
هذه التحديات لا يمكن حلها عن طريق
الحكومات وحدها
ولكن من خلال التعاون الهادف والموضوعي
مع
المجتمعات المدنية في القطاع الخاص والأفراد الملتزمين
[موسيقى] لقد
جئت لأرى تعاونًا من هذا القبيل ،
لقد وضعت النساء
في قلب هذا
المشروع بأكمله ، وكان جناح النساء قد أقام معرض إكسبو
2020 في دبي
والذي  يهدف إلى تسليط الضوء على دور
المرأة في
المجتمعات الآن وتاريخيا على حد سواء كما تذهب من
خلال سترون
شهادات من أعظم النساء في
التاريخ
، القوة الدافعة وراء هذا الحدث الضخم
هي وزيرة الدولة الإماراتية
للتعاون الدولي ،
وقبل أكثر من ثلاثة أشهر من
إطلاقه المقرر ،
جلست مع ريم الهاشمي وشريك
جناح السيدات الرئيس
التنفيذي لشركة الفخامة  العلامة التجارية
كارتييه
سيريل فيجنرون
إكسبو 2020 سيكون
أول معرض عالمي منذ القرن العشرين
يحتوي على جناح مستقل
مخصص للنساء ، ما هو التفكير وراء
ذلك
وما الذي تأمل في
تحقيقه لنا هنا في الإمارات العربية المتحدة
كان من الصعب جدًا تصور
منصة عالمية مثل هذه التي لديها
مشاركة قطرية
من جميع أنحاء العالم
بمشاركة من المجتمع المدني
والأوساط الأكاديمية
والشركات وليس لديها جناح
مخصص
لتكريم واحترام وتقدير
الدور الحاسم الذي لعبته المرأة
في المجتمع
حتى  من وجهة نظرنا ، أردنا
إلقاء الضوء على
هذا لجذب المزيد من الانتباه إلى
الفرص والفروع  allenges
الموجودة وتعرض حقًا ما يحدث
للمجتمع ما يحدث
للإنسانية عندما تكون النساء في المقدمة والوسط
، فلنتحدث عن هذا التعاون لماذا
كان من المهم جدًا
بالنسبة لكارتييه كعلامة تجارية
أن تتولى هذا المشروع ، اشرح ما إذا كنت
ستفعل ذلك أولاً.  لسنا هنا في
العلامة التجارية ، نحن هنا
في شركة مواطنة ليس لدينا
ما نبيعه ولكن الكثير
لنشاركه لأنه على مدار 15 عامًا من خلال
مبادرة كارتي النسائية ،
كنا نعمل
مع رواد الأعمال الاجتماعيين ولكن أيضًا
التقينا بنساء رائعات يرغبن
لتغيير العالم والقيام بذلك فعليًا من
خلال الأعمال الخيرية التي تقدمها كارتير ، فقد شاركنا أيضًا
مع الفئات الأكثر
ضعفًا وهناك الكثير من النساء المشاركات في
محاولة
اتخاذ إجراءات لدعم الفئات الأكثر
ضعفًا في جميع أنحاء العالم
سواء في إفريقيا أو في آسيا ولكن كما نحن
شهدت مع الوباء
بشكل أساسي في كل مكان في العالم ، فإن
التحديات التي تواجهها النساء
ستكون أكثر حدة
في ضوء هذا الوباء.
قال إيرال وأنا أقتبس مكاسب محدودة في المساواة بين الجنسين وحقوق المرأة التي تحققت على مدى عقود معرضة لخطر التراجع بسبب جائحة Covet 19 غير المقدر الذي سيدفع 47 مليون امرأة وفتاة إلى الفقر المدقع بحلول نهاية عام 2021. ما الذي تعتقد أنه يجب القيام به الآن لتحفيز الحكومات في جميع أنحاء العالم على وضع النساء في قلب سياسات التعافي الاقتصادي هذه ، لذلك عندما أنظر إلى ما نقوم به في إكسبو ولكن أيضًا ما نقوم به في الولايات المتحدة الإمارات العربية كما تعلم لقد فزنا مؤخرًا بمقعدنا لعضوية مجلس الأمن غير الدائمة والمرأة والسلام والأمن هو المستأجر الأساسي لعملنا هناك ، لكن عندما أتزوج ذلك بأهداف التنمية المستدامة لعام 2030 ، فإن آخر أهداف التنمية المستدامة 17 هي شراكات غير تقليدية نحتاج إلى أن نبدأ في أن نكون أكثر إبداعًا حول نموذج أصحاب المصلحة المتعددين الذي يشمل الشركات والحكومات التي تستخدم التكنولوجيا حقًا كعامل تمكين حتى نتمكن من ذلك  لا يقتصر الأمر على
تحديد الأشخاص الأكثر ضعفًا
ولكن لديهم بالفعل خطة عمل حول
إخراجهم من هذه الثغرة الأمنية ،
بل يتعلق الأمر حقًا بإلهام الوكالة في
الجميع وهذا حقًا
منطلق هذا المعرض
أنه لا يتعلق بصانع قرار حكومي
أو الرئيس التنفيذي  شركة من الدرجة الأولى
يمكننا جميعًا المشاركة
في رفع مستوى الكوكب ومساعدته في
استعادة الكرامة للناس
في جميع المجتمعات وأعتقد أن
الشعور بالوعي هو أيضًا تمكيني للغاية
يمكنني القيام بشيء حيال ذلك ليس
لأنني  وزير ولكن لأنني
مواطن مطّلع ،
فهناك الكثير من القوة لذلك أكثر مما
يراه العين في البداية ،
أعتقد أن كل شخص لديه دور يلعبه
وفي هذه الحالة
يكون للشركات الخاصة دور
أكبر مما تعتقده
، ولهذا السبب نريد  أن تكون أيضًا في هذا
التعاون مع Dubai 2020
لتكون مثالًا على أن تكون هذا النوع من
الطليعة التي تقول إن على
القطاعين العام والخاص التعاون
بحسن نية للتغيير من
أجل عالم أفضل و  o تجنب هذا
العقد الماضي
حيث يمكننا أن نرى أن الوباء قد يكون
أحد الأهداف الأساسية للجناح
وهو دفع عمل تعاوني ملموس
بشأن المساواة بين الجنسين ، فكيف تأمل في
تحقيق ذلك أتحدث
نوعًا من تجربتي الشخصية
كوزير في مؤسسة دولية
وفي جميع رحلاتي سواء كان ذلك في
أفريقيا جنوب الصحراء الكبرى أو واشنطن العاصمة
أو بنغلاديش أينما كان من الممكن
أن يأخذني عملي
، دائمًا ما يكون واضحًا جدًا عندما يكون هناك
منظور نسائي عندما يكون هناك
نهج شامل
لخفض منتج نهائي معين
والنتيجة وعندما لا يكون هناك ،
أعتقد أن جناحنا يتحدث حقًا
إلى
أن الأم تنتهي بدعوة إلى العمل ،
وهذا نوع من
التأكيد على أهمية وجود
هذا المجتمع
المنصف والعادل والشامل تمامًا
حيث يكون لكل فرد أساس شرعي
و  المكان الصحيح
الذي يدور فيه جناح النساء حول
تسليط الضوء على الأدوار الحاسمة التي
تلعبها النساء
في مجتمعات مختلفة حول
العالم ، وسيكون هناك  سلسلة المرأة في
العربية
والإسلام التي ظهرت
في الجناح ، ما مدى أهمية
ذلك بالنسبة لك ،
وأعتقد أننا
نستحق أن نروي قصتنا
بصوتنا ،
فهناك العديد من اللحظات والفرص
عبر تاريخنا
من القيادة النسائية القوية التي لديها
تحول
المجتمع وهذا تقدير لأنه
أيضًا اعتراف بأن المستقبل لا يمكن أن
يكون مزدهرًا إلا
إذا استمرت المرأة في لعب دور قوي
ومحوري في
المجتمع وهنا أعتقد حقًا أن جمهورنا
يشمل
الأولاد ويشمل الرجال لأنهم
شريك مهم  لاستكمال
العمل الرائع الذي تقوم به العديد من النساء في
المجتمع ،
أعتقد أنه عندما تنظر إلى رحلة الإمارات العربية المتحدة
وأنت تنظر إلى
الشرق الأوسط والمجتمعات الإسلامية الأكبر ،
هناك
اختلافات صارخة للغاية ولكن هناك
أوجه تشابه شائعة جدًا بين
محنة  النساء تحديات النساء
عبر الألفية وعبر الزمن
وأعتقد هنا أن
ما يهدف إليه هذا الجناح حقًا
هو أنها  قم بإلقاء الضوء على ذلك
، وتوصل في النهاية إلى
الاعتراف
بأنه إذا كنت تريد حقًا رؤية
الازدهار ،
فيجب
أن يلعب مجتمع عادل وشامل تمامًا دور
cyril إذا كان هناك شيء واحد
تأمل
أن يأخذه الناس من هذا
ما
لدي ما أفعله كل
شخص يقول إنني أفهم
ما يدور حوله وليس شيئًا
يقوله النساء ضد
الرجال إنه ليس شيئًا للرجال ضد النساء
إنه ليس حربًا تجارية
إنه شيء تحت الهدف المشترك
لتحقيقه معًا
وكل شخص يقول  لقد تعلمت
شيئًا ما وهناك شيء يجب
أن أفعله
لكل من النساء والرجال ، فنحن بالتأكيد جميعًا
في هذا معًا
وفقط عندما نتحد
معًا ، سنكون قادرين على
إحداث
فرق بالفعل والدفع نحو التقدم